um just a couple of notes for you all at
the top this morning we learned the
unemployment rate is 4.2 percent down by
a historic two full percentage points
since president biden took office prior
to the american rescue plan cbo
estimated that the u.s would not have a
4.2 unemployment rate until the end of
2024.
so this gives you that chart just to
give you a sense of exactly what the cbo
projections were uh and how much more
quickly we move to that unemployment
rate uh after the great recession it
took nine years for the united states to
reach a 4.2 percent unemployment rate
just to give you a sense the
unemployment rate is dropping even more
even as more people are re-entering the
workforce and looking for jobs that's
good news there's no doubt that the
biden economic agenda is getting people
back to work in november we added an
additional 210 000 jobs for a total of 6
million jobs in the first 10 full months
of the president's administration that
is a record for a new president wages
are also up and thanks to the american
rescue plan the president and
congressional democrats delivered
significant tax cuts for families
raising kids on average americans have
about a hundred dollars more in their
pockets each month than they did last
year even accounting for higher prices
the united states is the only leading
economy in the world where household
income and the economy are stronger than
they were before the pandemic and our
coveted strategy is allowing millions of
workers to find jobs and ensuring our
country can weather any challenges
without shutting down our businesses or
our schools we know that there is more
work to do and the historic buildback
better act will cut costs that american
families have struggled with for years
create more jobs and continue growing
our economy just some notes on the week
ahead for all of you on sunday the
president and the first lady will return
from camp david uh to host the kennedy
center honors honorees reception uh
where they will be joined by the vice
president and second gentleman they will
then attend the 44th kennedy center
honors on monday the president will
deliver remarks on how his buildback
better
act will lower the cost of prescription
drugs for millions of americans by
finally letting medicare negotiate drug
prices imposing a tax penalty if drug
companies increase their prices faster
than inflation putting a cap on how much
seniors and people with disabilities
have to pay for drugs and lower insulin
prices so that americans with diabetes
don't pay more than 35 dollars per month
for their insulin the president thinks
it's absolutely unacceptable that the
american people are forced to pay the
highest prices for prescription drugs in
the entire world two to three times as
much as other developed countries and
this is an example of how bill back
better will reduce many of the biggest
costs families face on thursday and
friday the president will host the
virtual summit for democracy bringing
together over 100 participants
representing governments civil society
and private sector leaders the president
will deliver the
the summit opening and closing remarks
and we'll participate in plenary
sessions i know we've previewed some
components of that and we'll have more
in the coming days go ahead alex thanks
jen i have a few questions on russia and
then one on two sure so today putin's
foreign affairs advisor total federation
arrangements have been made for putin by
the new call in the coming days can you
tell us anything about that will there
be a call with valencia as well and then
can you clarify what the president meant
when he said earlier he's putting
together a quote comprehensive and
meaningful set of initiatives to deter
tokens and then one more on that um does
the administration think that ukraine is
to do anything
more than it's doing to deter russia
should there be decisions from ukraine
well let me start with the second one uh
first and then i'll try to make sure i
cover all of them uh first well i can't
of course speak to russian intentions i
think you've heard
us and secretary of state lincoln
expressed growing concerns about what
we're seeing on the border
of russia and ukraine he has been in
europe this week consulting with our
partners european partners and we have
also been consulting at the same time
closely with congress and we want to
make sure
that we are prepared we know uh what
president putin has done in the past
we see that he is putting in place the
capacity to
to take action in short order and should
he decide to invade uh that is why we
want to be prepared uh and
in an area we have expressed serious
concern about so uh what he means by a
group of us a package is there's a range
of tools at our disposal of course
economic sanctions are an option but we
are going to do that in coordination
with our european partners with congress
those consultations have been ongoing
and we just want to be prepared as it
relates to the potential for a call we
have been engaged in the possibility of
that um
when we have if and when we have that
finalized we will make that uh we will
make you all aware of that as you know
the president is somebody who believes
in a leader to leader diplomacy uh it
certainly would be an opportunity to
discuss uh our serious concerns about uh
the bellicose rhetoric about the
military buildup that we're seeing on
the border of ukraine
go ahead you have another question
ukraine yes
does the administration think that
ukraine should be offering anything more
to russia to try to deter some of that
rhetoric the actions that we've seen
well i think
we are not the only country who feels
that the onus is really on russia to
reduce their bellicose rhetoric to uh to
make some changes uh as it relates to
the buildup of military troops uh that
we see at the border uh and will really
the onus is really on them
uh the iran talks have not been going
well um there are reports that the
western negotiators told the iran
negotiators their opening proposals were
quote unserious um so will those talks
continue as planned is the
administration still hopeful for a
diplomatic approach
we are always hopeful for a diplomatic
approach that's always the best option
uh the seventh round of uh talks did end
today in vienna special envoy o'malley
and his interagency team are returning
to washington now the new iranian
administration did not come to vienna
with constructive proposals the first
six rounds of negotiations made progress
finding creative compromised solutions
to many of the hardest issues that were
difficult for all sides iran's approach
this week was not unfortunately to try
to resolve the remaining issues uh so
and even more importantly uh iran
started this new round of negotiations
with a new round of nuclear provocations
as reported by the iaea on wednesday and
they've still failed to reach an
understanding with the iaea to restore
the cooperation and transparency they
have degraded in recent months we know
why we're here the previous
administrations decided to withdraw from
the jcpoa that's led to a dramatic and
unprecedented expansion of iran's
nuclear program this cannot continue uh
and the president continues to believe
uh that there is a better alternative
he's committed to returning the united
states to compliance with the jcpoa and
staying in compliance so long as iran
does the same he means it if iran is
equally committed a solution is at hand
but we did not see that from them this
week
good thanks james uh first just
clarifying what you said in ukraine
there so it's fair to say that the white
house is preparing for the possibility
that russia might invade well we can't
predict from here what president putin's
calculus is or what the russians
calculus is we saw what they did in 2014
we've seen what they're doing on the
border and we're going to consult with
our allies and partners and congress
here to be prepared for a range of
options i want to switch gears totally
to a comment from a statement from
senator manchin last night he voted with
a republic he voted against a republican
amendment to zero out funding for the
vaccine mandate but then he got a
statement saying that he would actually
support that idea in the coming weeks
what's your reaction to manchester
saying that he's against the president's
mandate that much well one it's vex or
test um and obviously that is something
we feel we have every authority to do
based on a 50 year old law
that congress put into place 50 years
ago
we simply disagree uh we we disagree uh
based on what we feel is a preponderance
of evidence of the effectiveness of
requirements vaccinating or testing you
look at the private sector there are a
range of companies airlines hospital
associations who have implemented these
types of requirements effectively we are
the largest employer the united states
government in this country we have
implemented requirements and we have
seen 96.5 percent compliance something
we're going to continue to build on and
these companies and the federal
government are doing it for a range of
reasons it creates certainty it allows
people to feel safe in the workplace and
it's good for the economy so we disagree
on that front and we're going to
continue to press forward with these
requirements but to that point if the
companies are doing that i mean that's
mansion statement was that we should
just continue to incentivize companies
why
you know
what are you going to do if he votes
with republicans and tries to really gut
funding for these mandates i'm sure
we'll be having discussions with him and
anyone who is an opponent of these steps
but i don't have all the details of what
this would actually propose we're
talking about implementing uh
requirements through a 50-year-old law
it's obviously in the courts now it is a
good sign no question that companies are
doing this in the private sector but we
still feel at this point in fighting the
virus it's important to move forward
with these requirements go ahead just a
quick follow-up on ukraine um
russia has been pretty clear for the
past several months about what they're
looking for out of
the u.s out of nato
in terms of this crisis they want firm
legally binding security guarantees they
don't want nato and ukraine um they they
don't want to see a military buildup on
the other side um and they don't want to
see ukraine become a member of nato
where is the flexibility for the white
house on this are you willing to to
budge on any of those issues well nato
member countries decide who is a member
of nato not russia uh and that is how
the process has always been and how it
will proceed
i think it's important to remember where
the provocative action is coming from at
this point in time it's not the united
states it's not ukraine
okay so uh let me ask you about uh
abortion rights um you mentioned
yesterday about the president's support
for the women's health protection act um
which was passed by the house of the
senate and the house in september um is
awaiting action in the senate um
president biden has talked a number of
times about there being areas where he
is open to reforming a filibuster
preventing a default is one of those
examples that he's given is passing this
bill
one of those things and does he want to
see quicker faster stronger action on
that well again we we don't have a
ruling from the supreme court we don't
expect that for several months
the president continues to believe that
codifying roe is something that should
be done and he supports this piece of
legislation but i think we're getting a
few steps ahead in the process
but again that that bill was passed in
september schumer said it will come up
very soon in the senate back in
september
where is that and is the white house
doing anything to push that along
i would point you to leader schumer's
office on any status of when that would
come forward uh again it's something the
president strongly supports and he is a
strong advocate for codifying rowe
go ahead uh in the president's remarks
earlier today when he was asked about
his cold he said that he was he is being
tested daily for coping 19. my
understanding was that it was done with
less frequency of that i know dr
o'connor said that he was tested three
times this week but is there a change in
protocol where he is going to be tested
daily and what kind of test is he
getting antigen or pcr
uh yeah i think we just put out some
details from doc o'connor that outlines
how many times he's been tested and i
believe the kind of tests um that he
received he received those tests because
he had a cold which would be considered
a symptom um and but it's not a change
in protocol and so he's not going to be
tested daily no
and then yesterday um president biden
said that he spoke with senators
mcconnell and schumer on government
funding has he spoken with leader
mcconnell when it comes to the debt
limit and would the president be open to
tying the debt limit to the nda
uh the i don't have any calls to read
out for you but we are encouraged by the
conversations that are happening between
uh leader schumer and senator mcconnell
uh about how to address a range of
issues that are in front of congress
including the debt limit um and beyond
that uh we i don't have any update from
here good thanks jen just to clarify the
president didn't say he was tested every
day for coving so did he just misspeak
there well i think wish i would point
you to the transparent note we put out
from the doctor to all of you that
outlines how many times he was tested
and exactly what he was tested for okay
and then shifting to the
new travel policy that goes into effect
on monday
the burden is on airline workers to
verify
test results to make sure they're
negative
is the administration doing anything to
help train them so they know how to do
that and so that they can spot
fraudulent
results for example
i would really point you to tsa a
division of course of the government i'm
sure that they are taking steps to make
sure people are prepared to look for how
to verify but i would really point to
them for more details okay and the
president just announced it yesterday it
goes into effect monday
can you share what you're doing to get
the word out to international travelers
especially to americans who might be
coming home
are airlines sending out the message to
all those travelers uh this is not i i
would just remind everyone that this is
from from three days to the day in
advance so it is a change in that regard
it is not an entirely new component um
we have communicated that effectively i
think travelers have been able to abide
by the three day requirement uh we will
communicate through a range of channels
we've done in the past but we don't
expect there to be an issue
just one more quick one a lot of these
at-home tests
um
come with a stick so your test result is
the stick that either has one line or
two lines on it but the faq section says
that you need
um
you will need to show a paper or digital
copy of your test result so is the stick
the test result again we've been
implementing these requirements for the
three-day requirements since we returned
to international travel effectively uh i
would point you to tsa and others for
specifics but this is not an area where
we've had issue and we don't anticipate
them in advance of monday
thanks jen the buildback better plans
price tag is being described as
incomprehensible by congresswoman
abigail spamberger a democrat and
lindsey graham says that he's he has
heard from the cbo that they're going to
do an alternative cost estimate
and that it's going to cost more and add
more to the debt so is there any thought
around here to maybe waiting for
buildback better until a month that you
don't have this big miss in the jobs
report
there's a lot of things gathered into
that question so let me let me let me do
the best i can let me do the best i can
for you here uh in terms of the report
of a new cbo uh that is not exactly how
it works um there has been and let me
just start with the irony here uh that
there's an irony that a number of
republicans who forced an unpopular tax
giveaway to the rich that increased our
debt by two trillion dollars uh and
certainly didn't ask for a score for a
continuation of that legislation that
did add to the deficit are now asking
for a score an additional score post
this bill being concluded for something
that isn't even going to be law they're
asking about a potential continuation of
these components of the package that
again the president has said he would
pay for
i can't get into the psyche of why
i would suggest that it might be have
something to do with their opposition to
raising taxes on corporations that seems
to get under their skin a little bit we
disagree with them on that front i would
say the cbo has put out a score a number
of economists have put out scores we
have outlined in the past uh that cbo
does not have the have not have a great
deal of experience scoring components
like the irs tax savings that's
something that the the former head of
the cbo has also spoken to in the past
and that there are estimates about those
cost savings that lead to not only our
assessments of the cost and savings from
the package but the assessments by many
economists okay on the pandemic it's
been more than two weeks since president
biden had a call with she
and on that call we know he did not
press him to help with the covet origins
investigation because you said that she
just understands he's supposed to be
transparent so in the two plus week
sense has he helped and been transparent
yet
i don't believe that's exactly what i
said i believe what i said is that we
have pressed for this repeatedly we will
continue to and will continue to do that
at a range of levels i don't
unfortunately have any updates on the
participation or willingness of the
chinese to add and provide additional
data can i provide one other update to
you since you asked me about crime
yesterday and i have a little more
information for you um oh crime my
question was about she
well you asked me a question about crime
yesterday okay so i was going to give
you a little a little extra information
i followed up for you peter um so i
would note what i
should have added yesterday but i
learned afterwards is that um the
justice department the fbi and the
federal law enforcement have been in
touch in contact with jurisdictions
where we have seen uh this high level of
retail theft so for example in los
angeles we've seen a rash of robberies
the fbi is providing assistance to
multi-jurisdictional task force led by
the li police department i'd also note
that on top of that the department of
justice announced last week that san
francisco where a number of high-profile
retail thefts have happened we'll get
money to hire 50 more police officers
through the cops program that the
president has championed that came as
part of nearly 150 million dollars in
similar grants nationwide so just a few
updates for you thank you for that uh we
will include that i look forward to
seeing it on fox later today it's on fox
right now okay i bet it is uh
one more topic to follow up on some of
the questions from earlier
the president was hoarse and coughing
today
a lot of people in the workforce are
encouraged not to go to work if they are
exhibiting those symptoms even if they
are fully vaccinated so are the rules
different for the president
the president again was tested uh as we
put out in some and a transparent piece
of information from his doctor where he
received a response quickly from that
test enable him enabling him to proceed
people also had he had a cold uh which
is what you know uh from the information
put out by the doctor but as you know
from your own experience it is possible
to test negative
several times before there's a positive
test so is there any concern about
having him at work while he's got these
symptoms even if he is showing negative
i i can assure you uh that the president
follows every protocol he wants to keep
uh everyone safe in the white house and
that's why uh obviously he we consult
with the doctor and we put out that
information to make it available to all
of you go ahead if i can ask you about
the announcement the president made
yesterday right now some european
countries are subsidizing the testing
process overseas the decision was
announced here that uh that the
government would be having americans
submit to insurance for reimbursement
why that decision and not follow what's
been a successful path for a lot of
european countries which is the
subsidizing of those tests
well i would note first peter that
the announcement made yesterday builds
on the steps we've taken to date which
includes
ensuring there are eight fda approved
tests available out in the market home
tests there were none available at the
beginning there were half that number
available just a few months ago we've
also quadrupled the size of our testing
program and capacity just since this
summer
we've also invested billions of dollars
here in the testing market that market
here includes reliable tests that meet
the fda's gold standard some of those
tests might not meet that standard and
that's what we think the american people
expect and deserve we also want to
ensure the testing market continues
scaling up and remains competitive and
innovative we believe this will help
drive down costs so our view is we want
to and we share the objective with
others we want to make them more
accessible we want to lower the cost of
tests we also announced that we're going
to be donating 50 million tests to rural
and community health centers uh that's
what we're trying to achieve here and we
feel this builds on the steps we've
already taken to date but we have
different tests we have different uh
market approaches here and we're going
to continue to build on what we're doing
here in the united states the president
his remarks earlier today said talking
about progress is not enough if
americans aren't seeing it aren't
effectively feeling it in their everyday
lives why do you think that is that
americans aren't feeling it yet is that
a policy
issue is it a messaging issue
what's the disconnect
well i i've answered versions of those
questions before but i we feel here that
uh kovid still has an
overlaying effect impact on people uh
and how they're uh seeing things day to
day uh for for good reason uh people's
lives don't look like they did a few
years ago you're worried about going to
work you're worried about your kids
getting sick uh you you're worried about
whether you're going to be safe in a
restaurant or going to a concert uh that
impacts how people feel about how
they're experiencing the economy and
there's no question as much as we're
seeing encouraging economic data data
doesn't move people i can tell you that
as a communicator their experiences in
their daily lives move people so uh he's
going to be out there talking about how
his plans will lower their costs make
their lives better and hopefully that
will give people a bridge to what he's
trying to achieve here little thoughts
just following up on the questions about
his health obviously like everybody else
we wish that he will get well soon the
question though is given the fact that
he has a cold right now are there any
things that are being done differently
have meetings been scaled back is he
doing something separately or is
everything continuous planned given the
test since continuing his plan he's
taking some over-the-counter cold
medication um and probably some cough
drops and some tea uh but otherwise he's
proceeding with his schedule and then
just just finally to punctuate that very
quickly just for clarity you said
earlier that the reason he had these
tests was because he was showing
symptoms so
he gets tested though when he's not
showing symptoms correct yes on a
regular basis not as frequently and even
cold symptoms
this week was because he was showing
symptoms on other weeks it would be less
than the three times exactly exactly
thank you for the clarification go ahead
back on the new requirement for
international travel to the united
states what gives you confidence that it
won't be an issue or a problem for
travelers coming to the united states
having to get a test one day before
supporting their flex are you confident
that there's gonna be enough supply
accessibility for every traveler who
wants to come here everywhere in the
world
well there have been uh some exemptions
announced by the state department where
tests are not as readily available so we
look at all of the factors here steve
and we're not trying to make it more
difficult for people to return home
we're trying to take every step to
protect the american public
there have already been these
requirements in place for three days so
yes it is a difference but people who
have traveled uh have adjusted to that
requirement and this is just narrowing
that requirement
the
requirement expect monday
what is your advice right now to
americans who are watching or listening
to this
they have only a few days left what
should they do
americans who are here or american
civilians who are abroad and tuned into
this briefing
sure no i just wanted to make sure i
understood
a day in advance of their international
flight they should get a test
as opposed to three days in advance
that's the difference go ahead sabrina
thank you jen a number of cities
including new york la san francisco
require proof of vaccination to access
indoor dining bars and other
non-essential businesses
given the new variant does the
administration believe that more cities
and localities should enact similar
proof of vaccination requirements
they may decide to do that
our our approach and our view has always
been that's up to cities and localities
uh it is not as you know that cdc
guidance has changed on this front
there's a lot we don't know about the
variant we're learning more every single
day
but again we continue to believe that's
up to state states and localities and
what they need to do to protect people
in their community
similarly with respect to states of
cities and localities
there are a number of cities that still
have not reinstated mass mandates
but they do fall within the substantial
or high transmission uh category that
the cdc has outlined for areas where
there should be indoor mass mandates in
place so do you think cities like dc and
new york which are still in substantial
or high transmissions abide by the cdc
guidelines of course they should every
city should uh i would note just this
wasn't exactly your question but i
thought this was an interesting piece of
data as it relates to vaccination rates
yesterday uh one million people
received booster shots 2.2 million shots
total that's our highest day since may
so just to give you a sense um of
how people are consuming information we
obviously don't want that to be a
response you know our objective is not
for people to be scared that is not what
we're trying to do here but certainly
you're seeing that the impact of how
this is being communicated about is
being felt in communities people are
taking steps to protect themselves go
ahead um in the state dining room
earlier the president said he was
putting together the most comprehensive
and meaningful set of initiatives to
make it very difficult
to go ahead with actions towards ukraine
are any of those initiatives military in
nature
uh well i'm not going to outline them in
more detail from here but i would note
that obviously economic sanctions and a
range of formats economic steps are
always a part of the option
we have of course
provided a range of security assistance
to ukraine in the past and that's
something that remains under
consideration
but uh that's what i can preview at this
point in time just on the next tranche
of fed nominees has president biden
finished the interviews for those three
slots i don't have any update on the
personnel process uh he continued you
can all continue to plan for him to
announce uh the additional nominees uh
in in short due time um but i don't have
an in the update on the day
go ahead thank you very much
uh
winter is very
close enough because it still has a bad
situation food crisis
any plan of united states for
humanitarian
access to afghan people
and also
u.s
victim family 911 they expect to receive
some money from the frozen money
in afghanistan
do you have any comment about that
although afghan people
lost so many people like 165
people as that have been dead in
afghanistan and osama bin laden was
found in pakistan
i think that the 9 11 veteran family
received this expect this amount
from pakistani authority
i would just note on the last question
you asked very important question um
good question it's under the department
of justice is really the right entity to
discuss that with uh there's uh some
discussion of litigation around that
with with some of the 911 families so i
would point you to them on that
in that regard
on the earlier question you asked about
humanitarian assistance absolutely the
united states continues to be the
largest if not one of the largest
providers of humanitarian assistance to
the afghan people in the world uh we
will continue to discuss with our
partners with the un uh with others the
best means of getting that assistance to
the afghan people
and that is an ongoing discussion and
one we were we are committed to
continuing to contribute to go ahead
yeah jen thank you um germany has
decided that unvaccinated people should
not be allowed to go in to public places
um
that may be a great way to incentivize
people to be vaccinated
let's assume that would not fly in this
country let me ask the serious part of
the question
really is
there seems to be no matter what just 27
30
of the population the eligible
population that refuses to be vaccinated
for a variety of reasons it's a little
lower than that i mean more than 82
percent of people have received their
first dose
but what makes the president think that
this new winter initiative of trying to
get people to get vaccinated what makes
it what makes him
feel confident that that's going to work
on those people who absolutely refuse to
be vaccinated well first we know what
works i would remind you that almost a
year ago only about 30 percent of
eligible adults in this country
felt open to getting vaccinated now
we're 80 more than 82 percent have
received one at least one dose uh that
is clearly not against part on partisan
lines um because uh you know you know
how divided our country can be uh that
are those those are people who took a
step to protect themselves to protect
their neighbors to protect their loved
ones i'd also note that we saw i just
gave you some data on the vaccination
rate from just yesterday
the highest we have seen since may and
we know that vaccinations are what can
save lives but also it's important to
continue to build our testing and
masking capacity that's what we also
announced yesterday so i would just say
we know what works we also know what's
standing in the way and you're right
there are things that we uh can't change
uh for reasons i will
never begin to understand uh some
members of the republican party have
decided that their political uh platform
is going to be running in favor of
protecting people from getting
vaccinated or from getting tested that's
why people try some people try to shut
down the government
as crazy as that sounds
people hear that they hear
misinformation traveling on social media
those are all entities we're fighting uh
but you're right there are some forces
against us
the president threw up his hands
never you can't do that as president go
ahead just a real quick clarification
the letter that you all sent out um from
the present time does not indicate
whether the covent test was a pcr test
okay fair i will get the clarification
from him absolutely i read it too
quickly up here yes it's important given
the difference
okay sounds great go ahead thank you jen
uh
my question is about the travel
restrictions and
right now the african people still very
concerned about these restrictions
because
because of that uh there is a little
chaos in the continent because many
countries are closing their borders and
people are not traveling as usual and
many people in africa still have problem
to really understand the real reasons
behind those travel restrictions
so
and why is still in place you have said
in the past that there is no political
reasons behind this decision
and the president and you yourself have
mentioned that this is to protect the
american people and it's for the safety
of the american people
but if this was really about the safety
of the american people why some
countries in europe and even canada that
has the variant are not included on this
travel restriction list and even african
countries that doesn't have the variant
are on the list
so
how do you explain to the african people
who are watching you right now
that there is no political reasons
behind even though it looks like there
is
so i would say directly to the people in
africa that uh these restrictions were
announced a week ago
on the recommendation of our health and
medical experts because what we saw and
and what we have continues to see is
that in south africa the variant and the
spread of the variant led to hundreds
and thousands of cases and i don't have
the exact number in front of me but now
it's definitely far into the thousands
of cases uh we also put the restrictions
were recommended by our health and
medical experts for neighboring
countries these steps were taken in
order to slow the spread of the variant
and to give our medical experts here
more time to assess this variant and
more time to assess what we needed to do
to protect people in the united states
at the same time we have been donating
not only vaccines but know-how and
expertise to south africa to neighboring
countries and we've been in touch with
officials there on a daily basis as we
help to work to address this variant and
this virus and we are assessing on a
daily basis what is needed uh whether
it's adding additional restrictions or
removing restrictions so that's what i
would say go ahead i think i have to
keep going i'm sorry i have to keep
going because we're going to run out of
time okay last one yes we in uh have
seen president biden in the past uh
strongly defend the south african people
from the apartheid virgin when he was in
congress and not only that even uh
normally he used to advocate for the
rights of the african people does the
mind of president biden change over the
time towards the africans
absolutely not
what we're trying to do here is work in
partnership to address ovarian and
address a virus and we are in touch on a
daily basis with leaders there with
health officials there about everything
we can do to be a partner in that effort
at the same time the president needs to
take steps to err on the side of
protecting the american people from the
spread of a variant we knew little about
and we're learning more about on a daily
basis go ahead thanks um
apple alerted us diplomats that their
iphones have been hacked in these months
by spyware from the nso group and this
is the first confirmed cases of the
pegasus software being used to target
american officials i'm wondering if the
administration has any comment on that
i have seen this particular report and
i'm not sure what if the state
department will have more to say about
it they may
we have been acutely concerned that
commercial spyware like nso group
software poses a serious
counterintelligence and security risk to
us personnel which is one of the reasons
why this administration has placed
several companies involved in the
development and proliferation of these
tools on the department of commerce's
entity list
we've also mobilized a government-wide
effort to counter incur proliferation of
these commercial hacking tools but in
terms of this specific incident um i'd
i'd point you to state they may have
more up-to-date information on it and
just one more on
the shooting in michigan i'm wondering
if you have any update on whether or not
the president has had any contact with
state or local leaders or families
impacted by it and then secondly gun
control is obviously something that he's
talked quite a bit about there is no uh
he nominates someone for the atf that
nomination is controlled do should we
expect someone else to be nominated for
that the role or any more of a focus
from the president um on gun control
given what happened this week uh well
absolutely i mean gun safety is
something that has been a core issue uh
for the president for decades um as you
know and you've heard me say from here
before um you know he led the the effort
to pass the assault weapons ban to get
the brady bill passed and background
checks and even since he's come into
office in april he announced a set of
actions to reduce gun violence including
reigning in the proliferation of ghost
guns uh an issue that uh ghost guns are
something that has really been a rising
contributor to uh violent crime to
crimes out there and to gun violence
better stable regulating stabilizing
braces and encouraging states to adopt
red flags through the justice department
issuance of model legislation in june he
announced a comprehensive plan to reduce
gun crime the fact is there are three
bills right now that have passed the
house the violence against women act
which includes provisions to keep more
guns out of the hands of abusers the
bill to require background checks for
all gun sales and also build back better
which includes a historic proposal to
invest five billion dollars in
evidence-based community violence
interventions so this is central he will
continue fighting for this and he will
continue to look at uh what steps can be
taken through executive action as well
uh but this will continue to be a cause
for the president on your other question
i will check i have not i don't have any
calls at this point to read out i will
check and see if there's any update to
that go ahead
travel restrictions
once these restrictions are in place it
seems like it can often be pretty hard
for them to go away india had a travel
ban for months and months and months the
uk had a travel ban for like a year
um so are there specific metrics that
the white house is looking for to decide
okay let's let these people travel here
again you know especially given that
it's here
there's community spread in the united
states
and there are tens of thousands of cases
in south africa and there are a half a
dozen we're aware of here in the united
states that will grow and increase uh
i would say i would
refute one notion we can make the
decision based on the health and medical
experts and they're meeting on a daily
basis to roll back any restrictions
there are some as you have said that
have been in the place for weeks or
months for a reason right and if there
had been a recommendation to roll those
back sooner we would have abided by
those recommendations so this is being
evaluated on a daily basis um with our
health and medical experts and team we
really rely on them for their assessment
of when it is uh appropriate and uh and
the right uh and a science-based
decision to do exactly that and do you
know if there are any particular metrics
that they use for those decisions uh
there are but i would really point you
to the health and medical experts to
speak to that more effectively go ahead
and just following up on the afghanistan
question um
you mentioned ongoing discussions um
given the level of crisis that's
happening there and how it's worsening
is is there something more specific that
you guys are asking for
a deadline um is that will the president
entertain um
lifting some of the sanctions um
can you get a little more specific and
what well what i was trying to get at is
that one of the challenges in
afghanistan i think you can agree on
this is the logistics of getting
humanitarian assistance around different
communities and that's one of the areas
we've been discussing so that's what i
was getting at we have provided a
enormous amount of humanitarian
assistance and we will continue to um
and that is something that other others
of our partners are as well but we also
recognize the logistical challenges
that's something we've been discussing
so that's what i was referring to what
about the sanctions would is there enter
any entertainment uplifting some of the
sanctions there hasn't been a change to
that i would point to the state
department tom west obviously had some
discussions with the taliban uh but uh
our policy on that has not changed that
i'm aware of go ahead
the national debt is now over 29
trillion dollars that's more than double
a decade ago when then vice president
biden went across the street and led
discussions with lawmakers at the blair
house
you said that he's encouraged that
leader schumer and leader mcconnell are
discussing this issue um but does he
want any direct engagement himself do
you see any sort of scenario where the
president tries to strike some sort of
grand bargain like president obama and
john boehner tried to attempt a decade
ago
i think you're combining a few things
there so let me do my best here
one the debt limit is about paying the
bills that are already due right and so
our pr our proposal our preference is
always to do that through regular order
uh and just raise the debt limit uh to
ensure that we are uh protecting the
full faith and credit of the united
states
government as it relates to what the
debt looks like we agree
that's why the president was opposed to
the two trillion dollars in
tax cuts for the highest income that
contributed to a portion of that that's
why build back better is entirely paid
for
by
asking corporations and highest income
americans to pay more so
the debt limit i would say is uh you
know the president is encouraged by the
conversations between leader schumer and
senator mcconnell
and what his hope is is that we can
through regular order raise the debt
limit as has been done 81 times in the
past so we don't play around with the
full faith and credit of the united
states
go ahead uh thanks jen uh there's
reporting on an alleged chinese
submarine in the taiwan street has the
president been briefed on that is he
concerned about it potentially
escalating into an unintended conflict
and just on a more broader
level is the administration preparing
for any kind of uh potential increased
chinese provocations either in the
taiwan straits south china sea anywhere
in case beijing decided to express their
frustration ahead of the democracy
summit uh well i would say first we
always raise concerns we have about uh
any provocations or escalatory behavior
uh that we see i have not seen this
exact report so let me check with our
national security team and see if
there's more that we can get back to all
of you good now just to double check
some more reporting that the sheriff is
pursuing or planning an in-person summit
between the u.s and asean leaders in
january can you confirm that
i'm not tracking that plan but i will
check and see where was that supposed to
be i think it was reported by uh some
asian media including japan oh got it
okay the austin summit i will get you to
see if there's more details on that go
ahead jen you've been clear going back
until at least september every time i
ask about the administration's position
on the uyghur forced labor prevention
act you've said numerous times that the
president doesn't have a position
there's new reporting in the washington
post that in october the deputy
secretary of state was telling lawmakers
to slow the bill down
so is the administration on the same
page
and why does it seem that the deputy
secretary of state was saying in private
to lawmakers to slow this down while in
public the white house has been saying
that the president is neutral well i
wouldn't say we're neutral i i would say
we share congress's concern about forced
labor in xinjiang and in fact have taken
a number of concrete measures as you
know on our own including but not
limited to visa restrictions global
magnitsky and other financial sanctions
export controls import restrictions the
release of a business advisory and
rallying the g7 to commit action so i
would say we are hardly neutral we have
strong concerns serious concerns and we
are absolutely not lobbying in any way
against the passage of this bill uh
there are negotiations and discussions
between members of congress the
executive branch often offers congress
technical advice to make legislation
effective and implementable by the
agencies responsible those are the
conversations that are happening but we
absolutely support uh and have been
advocates for uh doing more to hold uh
to put in place accountability here
a number of executive steps the
president has taken and then also how
he's rallied the world uh you know at
the g7
on this issue
does he want congress to do anything
additional i mean is he he's leaving on
the world stage is he going to leaving
congress in terms of actually getting
something there's negotiations he fully
supports uh between members of congress
and he supports the objective of uh
doing more here and and as is evidenced
by the fact that we have done a great
deal we're offering technical assistance
again we're not lobbying against this
bill in any way shape or form that's a
normal part of the process in order to
make sure we legislation can be
effective and implementable that's where
the status of it is at this point in
time we gotta we gotta wrap it up go
ahead thanks jen i wanted to ask you
about mitch landrieu's team the
infrastructure sure can you talk about
what specific tasks that team is going
to be handling what kind of staff he's
going to get and who they're already
meeting with and working with
well in terms of the staffing question i
think that's still being determined
but what his uh what his role will be i
would say is akin to the role gene
sperling has had in implementing uh the
bipartisan infrastructure
piece of legislation that includes uh
engaging closely with local elected
officials mayors governors fortunately
he's got some experience doing exactly
that it includes working closely with
agencies and he has this uh group of
agency leaders he meets with on a
regular basis to talk about what their
plans are for implementation so it
includes overseeing all of those
components to make sure this
piece of legislation is effectively
implemented and has done so
with
minimizing eliminating waste fraud and
abuse talk about uh you mentioned mayors
and governors that he's working with a
lot of this money through grants is
going to end up with those local cities
who have to distribute it in whatever
way they're going to
are you at all like how are you you
mentioned that he's talking to them but
are you doing anything to prepare those
officials to be able to get this money
out the door and use it in the way that
the president wants it
and the law intends it to be right there
was an executive order that laid out
kind of the six priorities of how this
would be approach
investing the public dollars efficiently
buying american creating good paying
opportunities for millions of americans
investing public dollars equitably
that's the model that he is pursuing
this through there are a number of
different agencies that are overseeing
key components of the implementation as
you know uh some of these programs are
grant making some of them are programs
that are already up and running where
we're augmenting and adding more to it
you may have seen that there was an
announcement from epa yesterday right
about a project that was going to get be
underway to knock down and replace lead
pipes that's a program that could happen
on the earlier end we've talked a little
bit about how taking steps to continue
to address congestion at ports is a top
priority that continues to be
the case there are some components of
this massive infrastructure projects
that will require a longer term approach
because we want to do it effectively and
we want to do it right he is overseeing
all of that working in close
coordination with agencies and leaders
mayors governors in these states to
implement not just short term but also
longer term projects okay we have a
visitor today
hello great meeting you raphael um
from univision thanks for joining us i
like your backdrop um
what can i answer for you today oh can
we hear you uh-oh do you want to try
josh uh like as you can oh great okay we
had it we had an audio issue last week
okay
[Music]
okay hello secretary i can thank you for
taking my question i'll ask you
something that is a cause of concern uh
for our communities here in georgia as
you probably know our state uh is only
uh we have only 51 percent of our
population fully vaccinated some and we
even have counties where only 20 percent
of our residents are vaccinated
yesterday dr cameron webb from the white
house copy 19 response team told me that
stays georgia are potentially some of
the most vulnerable ones to the new
variant nevertheless our governor
brandcamp has been later focused on
fighting federal vaccine requirements
calling them unlawful and
unconstitutional and as cases of omicron
byron increase in the us and with
georgia is one of the most vulnerable
states i'd like to know what's the white
house's message to governor kemp
well i would say uh our message to
governor kemp is uh if you're not going
to be a part of protecting the people of
georgia ensuring that they can take
steps to save their own lives save their
neighbors lives and their children's
then you should get out of the way
because businesses are implementing
steps across the country including in
georgia to put in place vaccine or
testing requirements
hospital associations are universities
are
and people and what we've seen as one of
the biggest barriers and this is
something we can do from the federal
government is access so our hope is that
we can continue to work in a
non-partisan way with health officials
in georgia as we do across the country
to incl increase and expand access to
not just testing but also vaccination
that's something that we announced that
we're going to take additional steps on
yesterday and we're looking forward to
building on thank you very much
everybody have a great weekend i'm sorry
we gotta wrap it up more to come on
monday
thanks everyone
i'm so sorry
you
you